Life likes to test you.
And when you
make a bad choice,
living with what you've done
can be its own punishment.
Oh, my gorgonzola...
I recently got out
of federal prison,
and I'm trying
to get back on my feet.
Now, this is my life.
Take a moment
to examine the bow.
You're allowed
to hold a weapon, right?
Well, well.
That's my good girl.
Don't focus on what you can't.
Focus on what you can.
What is it you really want?
Ice cream.
And justice.
I've never heard
you laugh before.
It is unnerving.
What do we do
when we reach
the place where
we don't know what to do?
-Gonna get through this.
-So it will be like old times?
-Giving up is not the answer.
-It is good to see you.
We have to find
our own answers.
You shouldn't be afraid.
It's the first step
in moving on.
Read it in a pamphlet.
Maybe this is
the beginning of a road back.
There's gotta be a way back.
Okay, all right.
Wait.
This is a special chicken.
This is a magical chicken.
No spoilers.